where are you guys at right now right
now we're in our apartment where we have
been for the past month have it gone
anywhere besides Pedro going to the
grocery store yeah the new hot spot I
took a vacation to the mailbox it's a
little time out there
so what's it been like for you two I
mean I'm sure you've talked about this
at length but I feel like I got to get
into it with everybody because it's sort
of top of mind like for me personally
I've I'm Quarantine ting with my
boyfriend so we weren't living together
before and now we're together I think
for any couple I've interviewed Kevin
Bacon the other day the actor told me
he's spending more time with his wife of
30 years than he's ever spent before
so what's it been like for you guys
because this is a change for everyone
wee-bey like okay we was more together
before because Chantal
take a lot of time at the school you
know she's fake Alberti Aguas in the
nursery and the hospital I spanked
working and then in the workhouse and
now we have a little tiny morphine Joey
we're still together like it's better
time talking she want to coddle coddle
coddle and Makoto
kisses kisses kisses go don't pieces go
though well what place would you guys
say your relationship is at right now
better than ever working through things
where you guys back working two things
that the real point working through
teens does mean that definitions yeah
yeah we see how little bit things we
know agreed yeah but still they're you
know we when discuss things
Chantal what's your answer to that
question I agree I feel like we still
have a long way to go
well not as long of a way to go now
because we've been married for a few
years but it's always a working process
like you can't stop
what what issues are you guys working on
I mean in the past what you viewers kind
of saw you deal with trust issues you
know with issues with your family what
are you working on now I mean the issues
family issues are they ever ending like
they're never ending and I feel like
that's an ongoing thing that you just
have to continuously work at and I mean
hopefully certain things will just all
come out in the wash because you have to
get over things and let them go so
family is definitely still an issue with
us but as far as like him and I
personally I feel like we're getting at
a better place with our trust right now
I mean I feel like Mondays to TLC
quality time is never easy
but we're getting to this because if
people stick together you're doing
special right so what are people gonna
see on this special that's coming up
people are gonna see us in our homes
trying to entertain ourselves have you
guys seen any family in quarantine I'm
not sure if you've seen them in recent
weeks or months or what's that been like
no we're all trying to practice social
distancing really well I mean I've been
video chatting my family and talking to
them on the phone but we're staying
separate because I really would hate the
whoa just I would hate to contribute to
the spread of the corona virus and God
forbid I take it to my parents house
yeah I don't know how it might be
affecting a more filming of your family
reality show where's that at
we're not currently filming anything
right now
besides the the quarantine special I
don't know if you can tell me are there
talks for another season or for more
we'd love to see more I'm not sure if
there is anything else for us in the
future but we would like to okay how do
you feel like that because we did see so
many familial issues with you guys on
both sides both of your families how is
it affected your relationship with each
other and your families to film all that
and to watch it all back do you think
it's been helpful or or harmful what
what's it been like I feel like it's
helpful to film even the bad times that
we have in our arguments and everything
because when you watch it back it sort
of puts everything into perspective and
you see how you were actually reacting
in certain moments and you can process
it better and see if it was rational or
not and it gives you opportunity to it
gives you an opportunity to maybe right
wrongs
you may have not really meant something
with your family have you guys done that
have either of you gone back and made
amends with different family members
after watching what happened on TV yeah
we mean with each other we've done it a
lot like oh I'm sorry that I yelled at
you that way Pepe I have no idea what
she wants is not my and you know you
just go back when you find I'm a nursing
assistant my mom and sister work in the
school system we are a family of strong
independent women who don't rely on men
you continued again to provide I mean
just great TV for everybody
um what how has it changed you as people
to live your lives out on camera and to
deal with the fans and the haters - it
really hasn't changed the way we are
like our personalities are the way that
we conduct ourselves but as far as like
the fans on social media we have or at
least I have grown a thicker skin with
that stuff it did take some getting used
to having random people messaging you
like hate and things like that but at
the end of the day I'm I feel like being
on the show has made me blossom into a
stronger person with a thicker skin
who's more true to myself for me is like
I say very things like if you love me of
you hey my say thanks because anyways
you try to support and watch the show
it's like we I know a perfect we know
are perfect we solid people that try to
met
things work we know main like
prepositions reason sometimes we may
wrote the system but we try to do the
best but try to make relationship work
and some people doesn't like the way I
talk doesn't people know like the word
day you know they put some time my mom's
fair so my family but it's like I still
say like like you need to understand
there I know perfect I like simple
person they tried to find things for
working my marriage and try to put
Chantel together with my father at the
same time and then the people love me or
hate me and say I love you I love you I
love I love you well what do you what do
you guys think about how involved your
families are in your lives as being in
quarantine together made you think you
know what maybe this is good for our
relationship for our families to not be
so involved or do you miss them and you
want them back in the mix of things for
me and good and great we think what I'm
seeing a little bit more time because we
I never knew how much my family or even
your family would be a big part of our
relationship like they but in a any like
in every moment like I'm getting married
I never knew how intricate the families
would be to us I really I just didn't
realize I keep kind of joking that we're
gonna maybe have some quarantine
breakups and also a lot of quarantine
babies which category would you guys
fall into quarantine breakups and the
quarantine I feel like maybe we'd be
with the quarantine baby there's one
thing that you can do during quarantine
make a baby like it's like a bratty for
make a baby that's it are you guys
working on that no no I brought this
factor we just spread yoga night
I gotta tell you I don't know if you
know how you look right now but you're
wearing like a baby blue shirt and like
a pink shirt it almost looks like you're
doing a gender reveal party right I mean
okay so there are no no plans for more
little babies right now or any little
babies right now because we try to
Shanta try to be near school you know I
tried to get into school too it's like
it's actually complicated right now
because we want to bring with baby to a
good environment you know like where
everything is working don't they they
had like one family they can be perfect
for them no now with the olara
drama between our families because if I
want to bring my baby to me Republic and
and they say Chantelle mother say
something there I know camping there you
know so there definitely needs to be
more work between me and Pedro's family
him and my family before we would feel
comfortable with you know even letting
our child be out of our presence with
that family member honestly like I mean
that's a big thing that's a big hurdle
to overcome so I guess the I know I got
to wrap up with you guys but what would
you like what do you need to see happen
do you need to hear apologies from
people do you need to have certain
conversations like what proactively
needs to happen for this whole family to
be in a better place for our whole
family to be in a better place we need
to have conversations with one another
come to agreements you know mend fences
in a way there needs to be some
apologies and I feel like we can't be
civil with one another we are not civil
with one another honestly and I'm just
waiting for that day that we can have
just some common ground yeah are you a
news are the two of you civil with one
another yeah we're so
yes right so if your families were in a
good place
are you ready to have babies that's mean
I do so they're like more some more
chance yes it's gonna be more she better
chance gonna be a better chance know
that cuz I would imagine they want
grandbabies so do they know they got to
get it together yeah they better for now
is nothing like this
[Music]